hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast characterization of
immune checkpoint expression and
infiltrating immune cells in tumor
micro-environment by RNA scope ich I am
Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab roots comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
advanced cell Diagnostics a biotech near
and advance cell Diagnostics is a world
leader and RNA biomarker analysis for
precision medicine providing the most
advanced RNA analysis solutions for cell
and tissue based research drug discovery
and development and diagnostics and
molecular pathology its proprietary
award-winning RNA scope technology is
capable of detecting and quantifying RNA
biomarkers with single molecule
sensitivity and single-cell resolution
in routine clinical specimens the
technology has been employed in more
than a thousand peer-reviewed
publications by a rapidly growing
customer base of thousands of active
users the company builds strategic
alliances with its customers and
partners to develop companion diagnostic
tests for existing and emerging
therapeutics and also pursues internal
programs to develop and commercialize
proprietary cancer diagnostic tests to
learn more visit WWF CD bio calm before
we start there are a few instructions we
want to hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window and you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome Annalise Lera Mons PhD a
scientist in R&D and advanced cell
diagnostic
the applications group manages numerous
projects within the R&D laboratories and
with collaborators from around the world
they demonstrate new and exciting
applications of the RNA scope and base
scope technologies and also their
ability to detect RNA biomarkers with
single molecule sensitivity and
single-cell resolution within the
morphological context
prior to advanced cell Diagnostics dr.
Lera Mons completed postdoctoral studies
in cancer biology at the University of
California San Francisco she received a
PhD in cognitive and molecular
neurosciences from the University of
Leuven in Belgium after completing a
one-year visiting scientist position
focusing on medical entomology at the
University of Florida previously she
graduated as a bio engineer and cell and
gene biotechnology from the University
of Leuven for the six-month
international exchange program at the
University of Milan in Italy I will now
turn the presentation over to dr. Lara
Mons
thanks for the introduction and welcome
to the webinar everybody today I will
discuss the characterization of immune
checkpoint marker expression and
infiltrating lymphoid and myeloid immune
cells in the tumor microenvironment and
how the RNA scope in situ hybridization
technology can aid in characterizing DME
here is an overview of today's webinar
and the different topics we will cover
before showing the results of our immune
oncology proof-of-concept study in
non-small-cell lung cancer and ovarian
cancer I will give you a description of
our innate group age technology that was
used to generate the data discussed
throughout this webinar our
proof-of-concept study is built around
two main topics the expression and Co
expression profiles of therapeutic
checkpoint targets and the immune
infiltration and state of lymphoid and
myeloid cells in heme regarding the
immune checkpoint markers will show data
on the visualization and quantification
of checkpoint expression within the
morphological context of the PME on cell
type-specific expression of PDL 1 on
heterogeneous expression patterns of
some immune checkpoint markers and
finally on immune checkpoint Co
expression at the
cell level we will move on to the RNA
scope ish technology here you can see a
brief overview of the technology it is a
slide based assay intended for the same
types of samples that you would use for
IH c or immunofluorescence this can be
either FFPE so formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded or fresh frozen or
fixed frozen tissue sections or cells
the RNA scoped methodology involves
hybridizing the target specific
oligonucleotide probes to the target RNA
and the target probe is a pool of
illegals that is designed using
established informatics tools to provide
an essay which we guarantee will be
single tongue specific detection is
enabled through an amplification
procedure that involves sequential
hybridization steps to build up a tree
life structure shown here schematically
and i will describe it further on the
following slides through this method we
are able to localize the tremendous
amount of signal to an individual
transcript to the point where we can
actually detect and visualize individual
transcripts as dots these point eight
dogs allow for subsequent qualification
of the detected gene expression the
first key feature of the RNA scope
technology is the probe design we depict
the oligonucleotide target specific
probe as these to emphasize the fact
that they have two regions linked by
spacer the bottom of the Z compliments
and hybridizes to the target transcript
and the top of the Z is the bait for the
amplification structure when two Z's
hybridize in tandem to the target
sequence it creates a unique binding
site upon which a preamplifier combined
and the amplification tree can build a
standard R Nico preferred target
sequence of thousand bases or more will
consist of 20 VZ pairs pulled together
and designed to hybridize next to each
other along the target region this
allowed for a tremendous amount of
amplification and signal potential
however only a few Z's are needed to
bind to the target RNA sequence in order
to generate enough signal for molecular
detection the second key feature of the
RNA scope technology is the actual
signal amplification as mentioned after
hybrid
with the target RNA each V pair creates
a binding site at the upper portion of
the V for the signal preamplifier to
bind each preamplifier combine multiple
amplifiers and each amplifier can
further bind multiple label probes label
probes can contain a chromogenic enzyme
such as HR P that generates a visible
signal after chromogenic reaction with a
substrate such as a DA B and then it can
be visualized under brightfield
microscope or labelled probes can also
contain fluorophores to visualize the
signal under a fluorescent microscope
lastly background is depressed by the
RNA scope si because the signal is
dependent on two Z's binding next to
each other on the target sequence if
both these do not bind then preamplifier
can not form a stable hybridization at
the top of disease and the amplification
tree cannot be built consequently no
amplification of nonspecific
hybridization occurs resulting in little
to no background signal combined the
unique probe design and the
amplification system ensure a high
signal-to-noise ratio the growth and
adoption of the RNA scope is best
exemplified by the number of
peer-reviewed publications we had our
first publication in 2011 and since then
there are over a thousand peer-reviewed
publications using RNA scope in high
tiered journals the graph to the right
shows how RNA scope is highly irrelevant
across multiple fields of research with
over 40% of publications in cancer
research followed by neuroscience and
infectious diseases this slide presents
an overview of all the RNA scope assays
that are available from a CD we have the
single X chromosome ik si for a single
target available for both Brown and rest
in manual and automated Fantana and like
a platform our niche cope is also
available as a chromogenic duplex assay
to visualize the gene expression of two
targets simultaneously and to visualize
three or more targets the RNA scope
multiplex fluorescent essays v1 and v2
can be used images for these assays will
be shown throughout this webinar here we
show the typical configuration of an on
a scope experiments so provided that the
target is expressed
sample and the protocol is full as
recommended the performance of the only
scope si is guaranteed because tissue
samples can be highly variable proper
sample preparation and the right
controls are essential to an RNA scope
experiment tissue samples must be
properly fixed and prepared so that
there is good RNA quality in the sample
and no background due to poor fixation a
CD provides guidelines on how teachers
should be sticked for optimal
performance on our si here you can see
three cereal sections from a human lung
cancer sample on which we performed a
manual read chromogenic
si on the left is a section probe for
our negative control probe B which is a
bacterial gene that is not expressed in
animal tissues as observed in this
sample
there should be no signal for this probe
in the middle panel is a cereal section
from the same sample page with our
positive control probe for housekeeping
gene PPI B as observed here you want to
see fairly uniform target detection with
a positive control probe indicating good
Arni quality from the results for these
control probes we can conclude that
there is good RNA quality throughout the
tissue sample and that there is little
to no background so we can be confident
that the local as pattern for the target
PDL one shown on the right will in fact
be correct next we will cover our immune
oncology proof-of-concept study with
data for both non small cell lung cancer
and ovarian cancer the generation of
immunity to cancer is a cyclic process
that leads to the accumulation of immune
stimulatory factors that should amplify
and broaden t-cell responses the cancer
immunity cycle is also characterized by
inhibitory factors that lead to a new
regulatory feedback mechanisms which can
help the development or limit immunity
although infiltrating C cells have been
correlated with improved clinical
outcome they are ineffective in
eradicating tumors due to their
inhibition by immune checkpoint
molecules in addition immunosuppressive
factors in the local tumor
microenvironment contribute to tumor
evasion by recruiting and modulating
regulatory T cells and myeloid drive
cells immune checkpoint inhibitors have
demonstrated therapeutic efficacy and
durable response for several internal
types in
Master lung cancer however the majority
of patients are either not responsive or
relapsed after initial response
characterizing the tme for checkpoint
expression with single cell and spatial
resolution may provide critical insight
into new immunitech critic strategies
and identify new predictive biomarkers
for stratifying patients most likely to
benefit from the immunotherapy
here is a schematic of the design of our
proof-of-concept study so in blue you
can see the process is proceeding the
RNA scopes essays first assess the e
tissue blocks are generated and undergo
quality control by testing our negative
and positive control probe as discussed
in the RNA scope technology section
after screening for RNA quality tissue
microarrays are created for both
non-small-cell lung cancer and ovarian
cancer in orange you can see the
different RNA scope assay that were run
beside single egg data for PDL one
amongst other targets we ran several
checkpoint marketpro pairs including PDL
one combined with Tim tree electri CTLs
4 and PDL to the multiplex ich IHC as
they was used to visualize tree
checkpoint marker targets being PD one
PDL one and Tim Tree simultaneously with
the CD 45 antibody as a marker for
immune cells the chromogenic duplex
assay was also run for prepares
indicative of different lymphoid and
myeloid cell types and states as well
the multiplex ich IHC assay for
interferon gamma cd4 and Fox p3 mRNAs
combined with the cd8 antibody in this
first data section we will highlight the
expression and Co expression profiles of
therapeutic checkpoint or occurs within
the morphological context of the tumor
microenvironment
here we Ellis trait the RNA scope as
they applied to not not the lung cancer
tissues for checkpoint marker evaluation
the lung cancer DNA has 60 patient
course with 56 representing tumor
tissues and for normal tissues duplex
data was generated for this checkpoint
marker prepares on serial sections in
the lower panel the expression analysis
is illustrated for one core on the left
you can see the core probe for to
checkpoint targets in red and green with
a higher magnification view of the
selected area for the selected area you
can discern how the hailer software
identifies and segments individual cells
and quantify the number of dots for each
of the two probes cells exclusively
expressing one of the probes are shaded
in green or red and SELCO expressing the
two targets are highlighted in yellow we
analyzed expression data as the percent
positive cells expressing selective
checkpoint molecules the result of this
quantitative analysis is shown here as a
heat map of selected course with red and
green indicated high and low expression
levels respectively
PDL one expression across the course is
shown in a top row and % PDL one
positive cells was used to sort the
course in the next slide we will focus
on these four selected course to
visualize the dynamic range of PDL one
expression
here we visualize the tumor expression
of PDL one across four selected course
to exemplify the dynamic range of
expression shown in a numerical table on
the previous slide core to be two
clearly demonstrates hi ppl one
expression with core to t4 on the other
end of the spectrum with very low
toonopedia one expression in between
course one g3 and fuji tree shown
medium-high a medium lochia one
expression in the tumor respectively
tissue core 3 to aid a hot or highly
inflamed tissue core with lots of the
news of infiltrated in the tumor
microenvironment well core to f1 is cold
and shows a low level of immune cell
infiltration for both course
representative images for the
quantitative analysis of each checkpoint
marker displayed by the rows will be
shown in the upcoming slides this image
from core to e2 visualizes the
quantified checkpoint expression data
for PD one in red and PDL one in green
within a morphological tissue context of
the tme as indicated by the red shading
in the table PDL 1 and pd1 expression
are high in highly inflamed core while
red pd-1 dot signals are present in the
stroma presumably on infiltrating immune
cells like tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes green Pontic dots for PDL
one mRNA expression are visible in tumor
cells in addition to immune stromal
cells with it being a higher
magnification image of the selected area
where stroma and tumor areas are
indicated by SNP and you can see the
higher magnification over here cell
type-specific checkpoint water
expression in tumor versus trauma is
very valuable information that while not
deductible from a heat map as shown is
clear from the sting tissue side what
you can see over here
in this cold tissue core with very low
inflammatory cells infiltrating multiple
tumor and thermal areas are visible with
one of each highlighted in contrast with
a hot - II - core expression for the
checkpoint markers PT one in red and PDL
one in green is low to know which can be
seen in this representative image over
here this image from cord to e2
visualizes the quantified checkpoint
expression data for PDL two in red and
Pia one in green within a morphological
tissue context of the tme as indicated
by the red shading in the table PDL -
like PDL one expression is high in this
highly inflamed core green pant 8.4 PDL
one mRNA expression and red dots for PDL
to expression are visible in both tumor
and stromal area which is especially
clear from these higher magnification
insects also noticeable is a core
expression of PDL 1 and PL 2 in the same
tumor cells with arrows in both insects
indicating some tumor cells with PDL 1
PDL - co-expression combination of the
same checkpoint markers in this cold
tissue core with multiple tumor in
thermal areas indicated should load - no
expression for these targets moving on
to the next checkpoint markers for core
- II - electrical signals are shown in
red again combined with PDL one mRNA
expression in green while PDL one is
expressed in both tumor and stromal
cells electric version is most prevalent
in immune stromal cells like tree and
PDL one appears to be Co expressed in
immune cells with some indicated by the
arrows over here
like previous checkpoint targets also
electri mRNA expression again from my
pic PDL one is very low in court to have
one characterized by a low level of
immune cell infiltration here we show
pl-1 expression in green combined with
Tim tree mRNA expression in red for
court reaches at a highly inflamed core
while PDL one is expressed in both tumor
and stromal cells as shown in previous
Pro combinations Tim tree expression is
most prevalent in immune stromal cells
what also can be appreciated from this
image is the visualization of the immune
Association into the tumor area with Tim
tree and PDL one co-expression
in so immune cells of which we also
highlighted some with the arrows over
here when we move on to the kholghoor to
f1 for these targets we see that similar
to previous checkpoint marker expression
patterns expression for Tim tree mRNA in
this low inflamed core is minimal with
some Tim tree positive cells shown in
this higher magnification inset in this
last pro combination with PDL 1 for core
3 2 we show ctla-4 check for an
expression in red while PDL 1 is
expressed in both tumor and stromal
cells are shown in previous combinations
abundant ctla4 expression can be
observed in immune stromal cells which
is highlighted by this higher
magnification image when we look at the
same target for the cold core to f1 we
see that there is very limited number of
ctla-4 or PR 1 positive cells it is also
shown by the shading in the numerical
table next we will briefly highlight the
self specific expression in tumor versus
throw myself for check mark marker PDL 1
as exemplified in previous section PL 1
mRNA expression was demonstrated in
tumor cells and film immune stromal
cells in this duplex only scope assay
PDL one expression in green was combined
with the tumor antigen
she met in red co-expression off PDL one
which he met indicated by but not
limited to the arrows confirms PDL one
expression in tumor cells noted here and
also on subsequent slides throughout the
webinar arrows are pointing out some
examples of cells Co expressing both
targets but they are not limited to
yourself pointed out here we showed to
seem at positive tumor course with CMS
in red and court three two on the left
is a PDL 1 positive tumor while core 2 a
2 on the right is a PDL one negative
tumor with no co expression of PDL 1 and
C met moving on to the next duplex si
PDL one expression in green was combined
with the tumor cell marker cytokeratin
19 in red co expression of PDL 1 with
SATA keratin 19 confirmed PDL one
expression in tumor cells which can be
seen over here here we showed to 1319
positive tumor course in red and cur one
day one on the left is a PDL 1 positive
tumor with Co expression of PDL 1 italic
Eric in 19 while for one if 4 on the
right is a PDL 1 negative tumor with no
Co expression with the keratin 19 in
contrast with the two previous tumor
cell markers this duplex or netskope
assay combines PDL one expression in
green with the immune cell marker cd45
in red while PDL one is predominantly
expressing tumor cells Co expression of
PDL 1 with cd45 confirmed earlier one
expression in some immune cells for
which we highlighted some with these
arrows also shown here is a PDL one
positive tumor for two course on the
left hand side of the slide and you can
see PDL one negative tumor 453 and also
cor to be true on the right hand side
another feature beside cell
type-specific expression that is not
feasible from the heat map is when
immune checkpoint markers have a
hydrogen
expression pattern in this section of
the webinar we will show some examples
for heterogeneous PDL 1 and PDL 2
expression in this image PDL 1 mRNA
expression is shown in green and the 2
delineated tumor areas displayed
different levels of PDL 1 expression
pointing to a heterogeneous expression
pattern for this target also know that
our new scope shows no signal when RNA
is lost in a chronic tissue with no
intact cellularity like visible on the
right hand side of this image a similar
hair Virginia's expression pattern for
PDL 1 in green can be seen in this
specific core with again areas with
different levels of PDL 1 expression
highlighted by the boxes and also in
this next example where there's clearly
different levels of Tyria 1 in these two
tumor for side a duplex assay for PDR
one in green and period 2 in red for the
highly inflamed core 2 e 2 also
demonstrates heterogeneous expression
throughout the selected area for both
markers as illustrated by the for higher
magnification images on the bottom a
different area higher up in the same
tissue core also is characterized by
heterogeneous expression for both immune
checkpoint markers again higher
magnification in sets on the bottom
showed this heterogeneous expression
pattern for this target in this last
section of immune checkpoint marker
expression profiles we will further
elaborate on the Co expression of
checkpoint markers at single-cell
resolution for this part I was focused
on PD one same tree and Lac tree
visualized by the chromogenic and
multiplexer and ich IHC assays this
chromogenic example illustrates the
single self expression of team tree and
PD one in red and green respectively
with some cells pointed out by the
arrows this type of expression analysis
could potentially offer insights into
why patients become resistant to single
molecule checkpoint blockade on one hand
and also uncommon notorious herpes
simultaneously
getting multiple immune checkpoint
markers on the other hand if similar
quadfession pattern can be seen across
multiple tours so here we show you
another example and also a higher
magnification zoom of this example and
again the arrows point to self Co
expressing PD one and symmetry but you
can also see that there is multiple
other cells to expressing these two
targets immune checkpoint co-expression
patterns were also visualized by
multiplex fluorescent dish for three RNA
targets followed by IH SP for one
protein in this example probes for
immune checkpoint markers PD one Tim
tree and PDL one were combined with a CD
45 antibody as a marker of immune cells
as can be seen here for core 1 8 3 DB l1
mrna is visible in green team tree mrna
is shown in yellow and PDL 1 mRNA is
visualized in red and so these are 3 RNA
targets that are combined with one
antibody cd45 and cd45 is shown in white
in this image we can also look at a
close-up of this selected area and it
looks like this so you can see that
there are cells Co expressing Electra
10e tree and cd45 so these are leg 3
positive 3 positive immune cells they're
also pointed out by the red arrows you
can also see green arrows and they are
pointing out PD one positive team 3
positive in yourself and there's also
white arrows in this image at that point
a PD one positive leg three positive and
three positive immune cells so deer
immune cells are positive for these
three checkpoint markers in this final
section we will switch gears a bit and
discuss in unisol tration and state of
lymphoid and myeloid cells in the tumor
microenvironment in order to assess the
infiltration of selected lymphoid and
myeloid subpopulations in non-fossil on
cancer the expression of several key
functional markers such as Fox Petri in
from gamma C XEL 1050 CL 22 were
evaluated in addition to key cell limit
markers like cd4 cd8 cd68 and CD 163 and
this resulted in following probe sets so
we have two sets for lymphoid cell types
beating cd8 plus cytokine in from gamma
with double positive for these two
targets being indicative for the
presence of potential significant
cytotoxic t-lymphocytes also we have a
combination of cd4 and the transcription
factor Fox Petri we're double positive
could be indicative of regulatory
t-cells in addition to that we have two
sets for my load cell type
cd68 for the chemokines excl 10 both
markers are known to be expressed in
several cell types including m1
macrophages then the second combination
that we have for myeloid cell types is
CD 163 and the chemokines CTL 22 which
are markers preferentially expressed in
alternatively activated mq macrophages
in this highly inflamed core 2 e 2 that
is shown in this panel we observed a
bundled infiltration of both lymphoid
and milo itself and the recruitment of
CXC alt annex present immune cells in
the local tumor region is clearly
visualized the presence and abundance of
a regulatory t-cells so Fox p3 positive
cd4 positive cells can also be evaluated
in relation to CTL 22 expression in
immunosuppressive local tumor
environment again in this slide also the
arrows point to the double positive
cells for these probe sets then we also
have this to see for poor for non small
cell lung cancer and that has low
infiltration of lymphoid and myeloid
immune cells as you can see here
especially in comparison with this
highly infiltrated core to e2 here you
can see the quantification of
infiltrating lymphoid and myeloid immune
cell death in the tme of selected
ovarian cancer tissues using the process
that we just highlighted for
non-small-cell lung cancer and we ran
these protests on for serial sections
the qualification is based on the number
of cells with positive adult signals for
these targets in this at the upcoming
slide we will compare the highly
inflamed core c2 that we can see in the
table over here with the low immunity
filtrated core a1
reproductive images for Corsi to
illustrate the high lymphoid immune cell
infiltration with interferon gamma
positive cd8 positive cytotoxic T
lymphocytes and cd4 positive Fox p3
positive T regulatory cells
so these out of four panels that you can
see to the left with a higher
magnification image for each of these
two probe sets that visualize lymphoid
cell types then we have also see axial
10 expressing cd68 positive and one like
macrophages there are also abundant in
this tissue core which you can see in
the third column with again a
magnification of a selected area for
double positive that you can see Percy
axial 10 and cd68 then there's also
medium infiltration of CCL 2 CCL 22
positive CD 163 double positives as they
are indicators of m2 like my load cells
and that's what you can see in the last
two panels we will look in more detail
at this highly immune infiltrated of
varying core and that's what you can see
over here so here is a substantial area
of course eat you with cd8 positive
interferon gamma positive cells that are
significant or that could indicate
factor toxic T lymphocyte a higher
magnification for these detected
lymphoid immune cells is also shown in
the left bottom corner what you can see
over here shown here is the same area of
ethereal tissue section with cd4
positive fox petrie positive cells and
these double positives are indicative of
T regulatory cells a higher
magnification also 4d detected lymphoid
immune cells is shown here in the left
bottom corner
the third Co section was proved for cd68
in green and chemokines expl 10 in red
with double positive that could be
indicative of m1 like macrophages if you
look at this higher magnification for
the selection for the selected area over
here you can see that there is a high
degree of myeloid in new cells shown as
a double positive
this fork Tyrael section is probed for
cell linnaeus martyr CD 163 in green and
chemokines CC algerian red with double
positives indicative of alternatively
activated and two macrophages again a
higher magnification is shown for this
selected area and you can see the double
positive for a CTL 22 and c d 163 over
here in this slide is summary of the
highly acclaimed course e 2 can be seen
on the top row and we you can compare
this way with the low in unison traded
core a 1 which is on the bottom and this
is shown for each of the 4 probe sets
representing the two lymphoid and to my
load immune cell types and you can
clearly see the difference between a
high infiltrated course with two on the
top both for limb forth and myeloid cell
types when you compare it to the low
influence core a 1 on the bottom and so
they clearly visualize the numerical
values that are seen in the table Co
expression patterns indicative of
lymphoid and milo immune cell types in
the small cell lung cancer were also
visualized by our multiplex fluorescent
fish for three targets and that in
combination with IHC for one protein so
in this example that i will show you we
use proof for cd4 mRNA Fox p3 mRNA and
interferon gamma and RNA and it was
combined with the cd8 antibody so this
is an example image for ignore small
cell lung cancer core and you can see
the staining pattern with the probe
smart as followed so the cd4 probe or
cd4 mRNA shown in green Fox p3 of our
nation in yellow and in from gamma RNA
is shown in red and the signal for the
cd8 antibody is shown in white and so if
we look at it close-up of this specific
area in the center of this core and also
for the other selected area to the
bottom we can see it
follows so the overlay for all these
four channels is always shown on the
left and then we have the single channel
images next to that so what you can see
here is we have red arrows pointing to
these cd8 positive integer from gamma
positive cells so presumably the
cytotoxic T lymphocyte then we also have
an example where you can see cd4
positives and Fox p3 positive cells so
these double positive are indicated by
the green arrows both in the overlay and
in the single channel images and so
these are double positive for cd4 and
Fox p3 indicative of these T regulatory
cell types thank you for attending this
webinar and I will be happy to take
questions from the audience now
excellent presentation dr. Lehrman
thanks for bringing that information to
us before it gets started with all of
your questions here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll get to as many as we can
our first question is what is the
recommended thickness for FFPE samples
so for FFPE samples we recommend to use
a tissue section with a thickness
between 4 and 6 micrometers can I use
that site to analyze target expression
so no you you can not for the size of
the dots here depends on a number of
double D pairs that is bound to the
target sequence as we showed in the
beginning of this slide deck and the
bigger the dot size that means that the
more D pairs are bound the standard
probe design is 20 DB per binding to a 1
KB long target sequence but if a minimum
of 3 double D pairs is bound you can
already see the signal so the number of
dots is indicative of the number of
transcripts so it's one-to-one but the
dot size should not be used to quantify
the number of transcripts can expression
be quantified in different compartments
for comparison for example tumor versus
stroma
that can definitely be done so data can
specifically be analyzed in selected
areas of interest so a tumor and stromal
area can definitely be selected we have
also done this type of analysis for
instance for electri and PDL one
expression in tumor versus trauma for
some specific course and that day has
been shown also in in previous webinars
and can be seen through the website and
in this specific case we could see four
into that like tree expression with
higher in stromal area for some course
while PDL one expression was higher in
tumor area so definitely stromal and
tumour compartment can be analyzed
separately and compared how many RNA
targets community tests with dual ich
IHC and is there a specific order when
combining these two assays so the number
of RNA targets that can be used in
combination with IH c is up to four
targets and it depends on which iron is
cope kidney user you can use three or
four it is also highly recommended that
when you want to combine ich I see that
you first run the ich esse and then in
the end you combine it with the IH c so
when you do it you should work with a
well validated antibody that you already
know that works in your hands also you
want to run the ich esse with the RNA
scoped pretreatment reagent Spurs
because this will ensure that your
protein can survive the protease and
other pretreatment steps that are
necessary for the RNA scope si so if you
still see single when combined the RNA
scope pretreatment with the IHC antibody
then you can also proceed and do the
dual ich i HC and also it is it's better
to target high abundant proteins because
of these protease steps but again when
you can optimize the antibody with the
unethical pretreatment and it works and
it should also work for the dual issue i
HC
can heterogeneous expression as shown
for PDL one be quantified yes sure a
heterogeneous expression problem
means that the cell display different
range of expression and that's what
we've shown in this type for PDL one for
instance so it can definitely be
quantified there's different ways of
doing it I will I can mention it briefly
so one of them is you can use a
semi-quantitative physiological scoring
method so we have a TD criteria that can
be used in these criteria are based on
the number of ducks per cell and that
way you can give a score to your sample
also image based software can be used so
as you seen throughout this webinar we
we use halo software but other software
can also be used to actually quantify
the number of dots per cell or any
specific region of interest so for for
this type of analysis as mentioned we we
use a low but a third methodology you
could also use the elaborate on this
software is that you can actually bin
cell with different expression levels in
two different bins so that way you can
get a histogram with a percent of cells
which in each expression category or or
bin and that way you can very easily
visualize the heterogeneous expression
that you have in your tissue so people
who want to know more about how to
analyze our native data there is a
webinar that can also be accessed
through the website that elaborates on
these three methodologies and gives
clear examples or singles like duplex
and multiplex staining scenarios can Co
expression be quantified yes sure so
again if you want to look for a cool
expression of two targets you can set B
the settings that you want for your to
individual probes and it will segment
cells detect the dots within the cell
and from that type of analysis you can
also get a number of cells that Co
Express these two targets so it's
definitely feasible can my target
expression appear as clusters and will
this interfere with my data analysis
yes it could be so you can imagine that
if you have a very high expresser so if
you detect that mRNA and information
with single amplification you could get
a signal that appears as a cluster so
what you can do at least in in the halo
software is you can set the parameters
for what you define as a dot so dot size
and so on and what it will do next is it
will say okay you have this size of
cluster and it will break it down into
the number of dubstep spit with all the
settings that you use to define a dot so
it's definitely feasible to still get a
number of thoughts out of a cluster of
expression is the new v2 fluorescent si
print from your existing RNA scope v1
fluorescent multiplex si so our beach
you know let me rephrase our v1 si is
primarily for fresh frozen tissue it is
also a shorter as they and contains all
the necessary components to run the
entire essay recently we also launched
the v2 version of the fluorescent essay
and this essay is TSA based and this
this this essay is slightly longer but
it is optimized primarily for FFPE
tissue so p1 is mostly for fresh frozen
and if you want to move to FFPE tissues
you can definitely use the viju essay or
if you for instance have a low expressor
or tissue that might have like high
autofluorescence we also recommend you
the v2 multiplex fluorescence assay 10 -
h IH c be performed on an automated
machine yes yes for sure so we have
d'lita bond Rx and also now we have the
Ventana discovery platform so these are
two automated platforms that can be used
to run the multiplexer as an SI well
thank you if we didn't get to your
question today we will follow up with
you via email I would like to once again
thank dr. Lara Moms for her
patience would also like to thank our
sponsor advanced cell Diagnostics for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 2018 you'll receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on lab routes comm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we will see you next time